مراسلنا عمر الحاج امين ربما هذه التطورات
في بالقرود وفي جبهات القتال داخل
اوكرانيا تتزامن ايضا مع موقف من موسكو
بخصوص تزويد واشنطن
بدخائر عنقوديه ضعنا في صوره كل ما يجري
نعم المواقع السياسيه في الحقيقه دائما ما
تتاثر تاثرا مباشرا بما يجري على الجبهات
والعكس صحيح طبعا هذه الاحداث المتسارعه
المتمثله سواء
باحتدام المعارك على الجبهات الرئيسيه
خاصه في بخموت وايضا في الجنوب تحديدا
فيزا باروج اضافه الى تعرض مناطق حدوديه
داخل روسيا في بيل جورد وفي كورسك لقصف
اوكراني طبعا تزيد من حده هذه المواقف
وايضا
تعبر موسكو طبعا عن عدم رضاها على الخطوه
الامريكيه المتعلقه في عزم واشنطن تزويد
كيف بقنابل عنقوديه وهناك تحذيرات من ان
مثل هذه الخطوه قد تؤدي الى مزيد من
التصعيد على الجبهات قد تواجه بتصعيد ايضا
من قبل روسيا ردا على تلك الخطوات طبعا
هذه المواقف السياسيه كما سبقها قلت تتاثر
بها الاوضاع على الجبهات هناك معارك ما
زالت محتدمه في بخموت موقع ريدوفكا
العسكري الروسي اليوم قال بان القوات
الروسيه نجحت الليله الماضيه في الحفاظ
على مواقعها قربه بلده كليشيفك هذه البلده
التي في الحقيقه لا تعد مهمه بقدر ما
المرتفعات المحيطه بها تشكل اهميه
والسيطره على هذه المرتفعات يعني فعليا
السيطره الناريه على مدينه باخمت باعتبار
ان
كليشفكا تقع في الضواحي الجنوبيه لبخموت
هناك ايضا معارك محتدمه في المناطق
الشماليه فيما يبدو ان الجيش الاوكراني
يسعى الى الضغط على مواقع جيش الروسي من
جهتين الجهه الشماليه والجهه الجنوبيه
فيزا باولوجيا عضو الاداره العسكريه
والمدنيه الروسيه هناك قال بان القوات
الاوكرانيه صباح اليوم
تراجعت من بلده بيخاتكي ان نجح جيش الروسي
في صد هجوم على مواقعه في تلك البلده
وحديث ايضا عن وصول مزيد من الدعم العسكري
للقوات الاوكرانيه في محاور زباروجيا
الجنوبيه ومساعي متواصله بشكل يومي
لمحاوله التقدم باتجاه دفاعات الجيش
الروسي عبر مجموعات صغيره عاده ما تتكون
من
اربعين الى خمسين عسكري في محاوله لاختراق
الدفاعات تشكيل تحصينات وبناء خنادق ومن
ثم ازاله الالغام تمهيدا لوصول اليات
ودبابات اوكرانيا كل هذه المحاولات تقو
روسيا بانها تصدها وربما نيران المعارك
سواء فيزا باروجا وحتى في لوغانسك في خارك
اتصل تصل كل هذه النيران الى مناطق سكنيه
حيث تعرضت احياء اليوم من جديد هنا في
مدينه دانياسك لقصف قاله القوات السلطات
المواليه لروسيا بانها القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت خلالها اربعه احياء في شمال وفي
غرب مدينه
في الجانب الاخر من اوكرانيا ماذا تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق بتزويدها
بهذه القنابل العنقوديه وكيف ستؤثر على
المشهد الميداني معك عمر
نعم عبد السلام القوات الاوكرانيه
والمسؤول الاوكرانيين يرحبون دائما باي
خطوات تتخذها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اوروبا بشكل عام من حيث تزويد اوكرانيا
باي نوع من انواع الاسلحه لان كل
التصريحات الصادره عن قاده العمليات في
اوكرانيا تقول الى ان تشير الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه كما يقولون تبذل جهودها بالرغم
من فرق القدرات والاعداد والفرق في
التسليح القوات الجيش الاوكراني رحب بهذه
الخطوه ولكنه طالب بالمزيد من الدعم
والعوده مره اخرى الى الاسراع في قضيه
توزيع تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16 والتي
لم يمانع الغرب حتى الان ولكن كما قال لنا
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني في مقابله سابقه
اجريناه معه ان هذه ان هذه العمليه طويله
الامد وربما تتطلب ثمانيه اشهر سيكون لها
دور كبير في الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني ولكن
ليس الهجوم الحالي الذي هو محل حديث
الجميع والذي لا قبل عده اسابيع على مستوى
الميداني فان مصادر ميدانيه قالت للجزيره
قبل يومين ان القوات الاوكرانيه جاده في
عملها في المحور الجنوبي تحديدا في مدينه
ضخمه قبل يوم امس كان هناك حديث عبر وسائل
الاعلام الاوكرانيه ومؤثرين ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من تحقيق تقدم في مدينه
كلاشنك التي كما اشار الزميل امين الى
انها تتمتع باتلال ومرتفعات تمكن من يسيطر
عليها من السيطره على طريق الامداد
الجنوبي في مدينه اباخمود وايضا كان هناك
تصريحات لالقاد الميدانين الاوكرانيين
تحدثوا عن تحقيقهم لتقدم في تلك الجبهه
الشرباتي تحديدا المتحدث باسم العمليات
العسكريه في المنطقه الشرقيه قال ان
القوات الاوكرانيه حققت يوم امس تقدما
بمقدار واحد كيلو متر في تلك الجبهات ايضا
كان هناك في الساعات الليل اقص من قبل
القوات الروسيه على مدينه كريبيري في جنوب
البلاد وكذلك الامر مدن
اضافه الى مقاطعه وهذا القفص تم وفقا لما
قالت المصادر الاوكرانيه باستخدام طائرات
ايرانيه صنع من طراز شاهد ايضا كان هناك
تصريح لافت لقياده العمليات العسكريه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه وقالت ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما تزال تتقدم بثبات في
محاور ميليتوبل وايضا هذه الجبهات التي
ظلت ظلت خامده خلال الاسابيع والاشهر
الماضيه والان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان
تشغل الجيش الروسي وتبدا هجومين من
منطقتين مختلفتين عدا عن ذلك مدن ايضا مدن
في اقليم دومباس وتحديدا في مقاطعه تعرضت
لقصف خلال ساعات امس وايضا خلال ساعات
الفجر والمضادات الارضيه الاوكرانيه
تعاملت مع العديد من الاهداف الجويه في
مدن
وايضا في مدن
كما ذكرتم الرئيس الاوكراني بث عبر
معرفاته على تيليجرام وتويتر فيديو لزياره
الى جزيره الافعى ولكن يبدو يبدو ان هذه
الزياره كانت في وقت سابق لان الرئيس
الاوكراني كان في زياره يوم امس الى تركيا
التقى فيه فيها نظيره التركي وايضا كان
حضر قد قداه حضر قداسنا اليوم في احد
الكنائس في مدينه اسطنبول الصعب مكان
الذهاب والعوده في ذات التوقيت طبعا
الرئيس الاوكراني كان كانت هذه محطه من
محطه زيارته التي شملت
تشيكوفاكيا وايضا بلغاريا ومدن وبلدان
اخرى نعم
شكرا جزيلا لكم